[Music]
hi
everyone oh gosh you all look so
wonderful
happy friday thank you for all
joining me i love fridays all right it's
fall
i've been talking about fall a lot
lately because i'm a california wussy
who has to like you know kind of really
transition with the weather
it's i am from an area that doesn't have
any weather
well i mean you know but just it's warm
all the time and so i'm not an east
coaster this is a whole
getting used to do you guys have any
fall traditions
anyone in our wall perhaps a kevin and
kevin
hi hi we absolutely
do hi kevin hi
no no not you kevin the other kev then
i'm just kidding
oh
what are your fall traditions
uh so we love to there's an arboretum
right down the street from where we live
and that's actually where we got married
and we love to just go
and walk around and be with the trees
and i occasionally
like to hug them so yeah
i am a tree hugger myself and by the way
being from california we have the most
extraordinary trees and i've spent my
life in fact i think it's like in my
will that i'm going to be buried under
an avocado tree not to be macabre but
i grew up like eating avocados off a
tree and
i had this tiny weird little duplex my
mom lived in it was like
you know really shabby and awesome and i
would sit back there with a spoon and a
salt shaker and
i think trees are also an amazing way to
see the seasons which is why i'm so
excited to be raising my daughters here
because
in california everything is a perennial
and here you have such amazing
foliage and like i love watching it so
thank you kevin
thank you kevin all right we have an
amazing show i'm so excited
because i get to chat with the lovely
and oh so delightful
james corden yeah
and we're gonna like talk you know it's
gonna be really awesome
um and i'm gonna give you the rundown on
some things that we love
that you might love too and our
weekender guide
but first let's hit the news deck where
that's where we serve stories
sunny side up it's drew's news
ma'am i asked you a question
[Music]
it's drew's news
oh thanks guys
first what do you do for halloween when
all you want to do is give neighborhood
candy to the kids
so you dust off the robot that you're
building in your garage
and you make him your halloween butler
that's right
at least that's what one man in austin
is doing this year
yahoo news brings us this story of luke
keys a software engineer
who built a candy dispensing robot
named artie addie
that's how you say it on the east coast
and the 20s
seriously if you're ever doing an
old-timey accent just drop your r's and
you'll be right there
luke will use an xbox controller to
pilot his creation
down the streets delivering sanitized
candy bags to all the boys and girls
i love this story so much this is a time
of innovation and artie you're the
robot santa of halloween and we love you
hashtag robot santa all right this next
story just hit me with the right amount
of spookiness because the new york post
reports that the mayor of the tiny town
of
hell michigan has posted his mayoral
home on airbnb
and offered to relinquish his title to
any guests for the duration of their
stay
that's right you get to be
the mayor of hell hashtag
mayor of hell if you're looking for a
devilish experience
nightly rates are just 31 and your soul
moving on we have news about a home
design
trend though that actually really moves
my soul
because it harkens back to my childhood
days this is flashback fines
[Applause]
i'm happy to report that conversation
pits are back
this instagram account it's so cool by
the way
it's called history cool kids and they
posted
the pics uh some pics of these 70s
throwback pits and it's sunken seating
areas with
plush cushions and fluffed out rugs
where you can have a hang
and a wine or a tab
i love that these are making comebacks
seriously sunken living rooms are
awesome
sunken living rooms
you